[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out bro and in this video we
will be talking about the giant clan
including every known member of the
giant clan the history of the giant clan
and the unique powers and abilities of
the Giants as you may know if you've
been following this channel for a while
I talked a bit about the giant clan in
our video about every race in the seven
deadly sins but with season 2 of the
anime recently covering Danns background
and the backstory of the giant clan I
realized that there is a lot more to say
about the giants animal DN as a
character that I haven't gotten a chance
to talk about so in this video we will
be delving deeper into the backstory
culture and powers of the giant clan
before we get started I want to give a
quick shout out to the seven deadly sins
amino app personally I've been using
amino for a long time and amino
communities are a great place to
interact with thousands of fellow fans
the seven deadly sins amino features
incredible and hilarious fan art
cosplays public chats and other ways to
interact we have our own profile so you
can check us out and share your fan art
with us if you'd like to see it featured
in a future video the app is totally
free and there are other amino
communities to discover like attack on
Titan my hero academia and more big
thank you to amino for supporting anime
uproar it means a lot to us just a heads
up there will be some manga spoilers in
this video and of course if you want to
see more videos like this one don't
forget to subscribe
the Giants look a lot like humans except
they are much bigger and they have a lot
more strength and they also have unique
abilities that humans do not giant sar
believed to be the oldest clan to have
inhabited the land of Britannia and they
have a rich and long history and of
course they are known throughout
Britannia for their incredible physical
strength and warrior code leading the
life of a warrior is the ultimate goal
for most Giants and in line with this
worldview the leader of the giant clan
is chosen based on who is the strongest
in battle Giants live
much longer than humans and they also
have a special ability called creation
which allows them to manipulate the
earth according to droll the legendary
ancestor of the Giants a Giants power
doesn't lie only in their physical
strength rather how well they can
transform the energy of the earth
determines the true strength of a giant
Giants can use the earth to create
powerful weapons of different shapes and
sizes and then use them against their
opponents in the holy war that took
place three thousand years ago the giant
clan fought alongside the goddess Fairy
and human clans against the demon clan
despite ultimately being on the winning
side of the holy war the giant suffered
significant losses including the loss of
drol an important figure in the history
of the giant clan and the individual who
is credited with inventing the sacred
dance of the Giants we'll talk more
about role a little bit later
despite their long lifespan the
population of the Giants has dwindled
because they are often hired as
mercenaries to fight in wars between
human armies because Giants are such
powerful warriors many armies want to
hire them and sometimes both sides in a
conflict will have Giants fighting for
them which leads to Giants fighting
against other Giants and of course this
leads to more Giants being killed in
battle many humans look down on Giants
as barbarians because of their warlike
culture and in fact the culture of the
giant clan can in some ways be compared
to other warrior cultures like the
Vikings
for example the Vikings believed that
dying in battle is an honor they didn't
fear death in battle they embraced it
because they believed that those who
died fighting would be rewarded in the
afterlife and gain entry into Valhalla
which is a heavenly realm ruled by the
god Odin
similarly the Giants don't fear death in
battle and they believe that dying as a
warrior is the greatest honor the
homeland of the Giants is mega dozer a
massive hammer shaped Mountain located
more than 300 miles north of the kingdom
of Camelot the giant that we know the
most about is of course Dion or Diane or
dn
you want to pronounce it like most
members of the Giants the N is a really
strong and capable warrior and in fact
it is repeatedly stated that she has the
potential to become the strongest
warrior of the giant clan however the
ant differs from the vast majority of
the Giants because she doesn't like
fighting or bloodshed as a child she
left the giant clan because she didn't
want to live her life just to fight and
that is actually when she first met King
now the N is certainly not afraid of
battle and she is prepared to fight to
protect the people she cares about but
she thinks that fighting for the sake of
fighting is just too sad her attitude
towards fighting made her outcast among
the Giants and some of them even mocked
her because of her stance on fighting
the ants highest recorded power levels
so far has been 48,000 throughout the
series we can see the ants
struggling between her strong sense of
loyalty towards certain members of the
giant clan and especially Matrona and
her desire not to fight the warrior
culture within the giant clan is so
strong that the only purpose a giant has
in life is to become a great warrior or
if they are unable to fight well their
purpose must be to give birth to
children who will become great warriors
the N obviously doesn't want to accept
this way of life and it is through this
conflict that the ant truly develops as
a character if you'd like to see me make
a special video analyzing the N and her
development as a character let me know
down in the comments next we have
Matrona nicknamed the fang of the great
earth Matrona is the former warrior
chief of the giant clan and she was also
a mentor to d n the ants parents are
both dead and Matrona feels responsible
for turning the end into a great warrior
and she is very keen on instilling the
warrior values of the giant clan into
the end even though the N doesn't want
to fight for the sake of fighting which
of course creates a great conflict
between the two of them Matrona trained
both Dee Ann and her friend Dolores in
the fighting techniques of the Giants
and she thoroughly enjoys training and
fighting in general Matrona sees great
potential in the end
and believes that the N can become the
strongest warrior of the giant clam
after she was tricked and ambushed by
humans and shot in the leg with a
poisoned weapon Matrona was saved and
nursed back to health by a human named
Salva she developed feelings for Zappa
and began living with him and his
children's soul and Della whom she cares
for a great deal and treats as her own
children as a result of the poisonous
injury to her leg Matrona had part of
her leg amputated and now uses a wooden
leg Matrona highest recorded power level
is seven thousand six hundred then we
have Dolores
Diane's childhood friend and fellow
member of the giant clan Matrona tried
to Train Dolores to become a warrior
along with the end but just like the end
Dolores did not like fighting and
whenever she was taken into battle she
wouldn't really do anything
Diann tried to convince Dolores to leave
the giant clan with her but the Loras
refused because she felt that the Giants
would never be accepted anywhere else
outside of their own community
while the Anne was away Dolores was sent
out on a mission to fight off a bunch of
bandits and she was killed during this
mission which resulted in her being
mocked by some Giants even after her
death for being defeated by measly
bandits we also briefly met Dumbo boss
warrior chief of the Western giant clan
he faced off against Matrona dn and
Dolores during a battle because he was
hired to fight as a mercenary for a
rival army nicknamed the great trembling
Mountain he was a fierce and brave
warrior but he was ultimately killed by
Matrona in battle Matrona paid her
respects to Dumbo boss for meeting his
end as a true warrior now let's talk
about role the legendary king of the
giant clan and inventor of the sacred
dance of the Giants believed to be the
strongest giant that we have been
introduced to to date draw was always
different from the other giants because
he was taller he has blue skin and
forearms instead of two as a child this
made him an outcast within the giant
clan and when she first meets him later
on in the story
DeeAnn can relate to drawl because she
was also an outcast for much of her life
droll led the giant clan
the fight against the demons during the
holy war 3,000 years ago and he trained
other members of the giant clan to
become stronger fighters his ability to
transform the energy of the earth
surpasses any giant known today however
during the holy war drol saw that the
goddess clan was often very ruthless and
cruel destroying entire villages full of
people just because they were suspected
of helping a demon at one point drol
also came face to face with zelgius of
the ten commandments but despite his
immense strength troll was unable to
defeat zell dress because celtris was
given power directly by the demon king
and was acting as the demon Kings
representative Zell drous told troll
that the word of his legendary courage
has been spreading even among the demons
and he gave drol a choice either die
right here and now or join the 10
commandments Zell drous told rule that
the demons are outcasts just like he
always was so he should join them
impressed with the power of the ten
commandments and disillusioned with the
actions of some of the members of the
goddess clan drol chooses to join the 10
commandments trolls highest recorded
power level was a whopping 54,000 later
on in the story troll actually trains
the N and puts her to an important test
and she passes the test by making a
decision that troll would have never
made himself I will talk more about this
if I make a video on Dee and her
characters so let me know if you want to
see something like that other giants
that we see in this story include the
village elders and other inhabitants of
Megiddo sir and also some Giants who
fought alongside drol during the holy
war 3,000 years ago but these giants are
never named and that is it the giant
clan and every known giant explained
personally I am really fascinated by the
warrior culture of the giant clan
because in many ways it is similar to
the cultures of real-life warriors like
the Vikings and the samurai I also find
the conflict between this warrior
culture and the ants personality
extremely interesting and this type of
thing really is one of the greatest
strengths of the seventh of the
since the story gives us great
characters with a rich backstory and
these characters continue to develop in
really compelling ways as the story
moves forward let me know what you guys
think about the giant flan their unique
warrior culture and about the end as a
character also feel free to let me know
what types of videos you want to see
next do you want to see a video on D n
on Melly Otis on bond on the demon clan
let me know if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more be sure to leave a
like if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell we are now posting
daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram so feel free to follow us at
anime uproar and if you want to discuss
anime recommendations theories and a
whole bunch of other stuff on a regular
basis feel free to join our discord
server link in the description as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]